let's jump to the story from The Daily
Beast
Ukraine joining NATO guaranteed to start
World War III Russian official says the
war in Ukraine is guaranteed to escalate
into World War III if Kiev is allowed to
join NATO according to a Russian
Security Council official Ukrainian
President Vladimir zlinski made a
surprise announcement that he had made a
first a fast track bid for membership
blah blah we know a lot of this all of
NATO's 30 members would have to approve
Ukraine's bid making full membership of
the defense group a long way off Kiev is
well aware that such a step would mean a
guaranteed escalation to World War III
so um and then here's a quote here's a
quote the suicidal nature of such a step
is understood by NATO members themselves
maybe one NATO country is just going to
say no we do not want to vote Yes on
being dragged into a nuclear war
but the one thing I can say is that if
you are between the ages of 17 and 24
because I don't think it'll happen right
now but you know that that draft age and
you support this war well I'm I'm then
I'm actually looking forward to you
being drafted
you go fight the war that you supported
all of these gen's ears with the little
Ukrainian flags and their Twitter bios
I'm actually excited to see you guys go
through basic training and then go be
the Canon fodder for the wealthy Elites
who want to win this region of Eastern
Europe how about that I would go even
further if you're a politician calling
for war go fight it we are more than
welcome Joe you're more than welcome to
join the the armed you know forces
what's stopping you if you really want
this go go and get it and I think that's
how we should be treating these
situations if we had an evolved Humanity
that said you know what we're not
fighting these stupid Wars we're not
going to die for politicians we're not
we're not going to die for these people
that are selling arms and making a
profit off of this nonsense
um we're not there we're at a phase
where of course we have a lot of lunacy
we have a lot of insanity and a lot of
escalations to this conflict that are
absolutely nonsensical there's no
purpose to us there's no larger agenda
here what's the goal here why are we
doing this can you even explain that
they can't there's no rational argument
for what's happening right now let me
let me ask you guys
is there uh is there a circumstance
where you agree with an offensive
invasion
is there a circumstance where you think
the U.S should declare war preemptively
and then invade a country before being
attacked
I mean that's that's a very open-ended
question there could be many differences
you probably can right
before being attacked I don't know so
the U.S sitting there mind its own
business there's another country that's
minding its own business but they may be
engaging in some activities is there a
circumstance where they don't attack you
but you think it is Justified to invade
that country well if you're talking
about a situation where you know they
are going to attack you that that can be
justified but what we've done in Iraq
and what we've seen other and what for
some degree Russia has done in Ukraine
is theoretically something is going to
happen someday that will allow them to
threaten us or attack us and we need to
attack them first before that happens
and that way lies Madness well that's
what uh zielinski said he called for
preemptive strikes on Russia he is also
causing calling for preemptive strikes
yep well then he walked it back no I
meant um reactive sanctions yeah
sanctions which there's already a bunch
of sanctions right wouldn't do anything
to deter in fact it would just
exacerbate the problem
I wonder I wonder if there if there ever
really is I'm sure a lot of the more
libertarian types are probably like no
there is no matter what some other
country is doing so long as they're not
attacking you you should not invade them
I think there are instances where a
military buildup could be uh you know a
cause for war like if like Germany
building up the tanks that it was
building up before World War II if if
France had been like this is too risky
to have that on our border because what
happened was they blitzcrigged and they
took Paris like within two weeks it was
theirs and uh that's what if you let
someone go full hog that's why they
built the liberal economic order was to
prevent other countries from going full
hog
but imagine you have a neighbor and
every day you say you see your neighbor
buying more and more guns and uh he's
got a massive Arsenal you can see it
through the window does that justify you
going over there having him arrested his
property confiscated or saying that this
guy is clearly going to be attacking
someone I better stop him I don't see it
now but there is there is an analogy
it's it's if you saw through your
neighbor's window him mercilessly
beating a child you would kick the door
in and you would get physical with this
man
or you'd call the police but if it was
mercilessly being a child for the safety
of that child to stop this act you would
invade that house right that's also why
that's usually the argument used for
invasions exactly it's never just that
okay they may threaten us although those
arguments are usually used too it's
about whatever humanitarian bad things
are going on in that country and let's
face it in most of the world a lot of
bad things are going on a lot of
governments are bad governments doing
bad things I'd say all of them yeah
preach sorry go ahead it's not very much
of a limiting principle for war if
you're going to justify it on that basis
but but then there's the next level of
the United States and other governments
staging these kind of events that are
not true that have no basis in reality
just like we saw in the first Gulf War
with the baby incubator story with
literally a PR team working for the
government engineering a story that the
Iraqi government was taking babies from
incubators and just murdering them like
like they they were just sociopaths that
story completely made up by a PR agency
that led to the first Gulf War there was
public hearings there was videos all of
them fake manipulated because again they
needed a justification so they made one
up they had like a young girl speak to
the UN about it yes and she was uh the
daughter of an ambassador
um that again was coached and staged to
lie on National Television that she
personally saw the babies taken out of
the incubators which was such a horrible
it's insane just just visualization that
it shocked people emotionally to say
yeah we got to stop this yeah remember
when they were I think uh the Russians
fired missiles into Ukraine like five or
six days ago or something like that I
think there were missiles or bombs or
whatever and then oh the the variety of
airstrikes yeah yeah and then all of a
sudden this video of uh the United
States invasion of Iraq shows up from
2003 what they call shock and awe and
the idea was we're gonna hit him as hard
as we can as fast as we can so that they
don't even have a defense prepared they
can't they just surrender and it was
televised and I remember sitting in the
bar in Chicago watching it and like
getting excited because I thought they
had weapons of mass destruction that's
what I was told and I was like good
we're gonna stop a tyrant from nuking
the world and I was excited like the way
that you can and and that propaganda man
the way that you can view bombing a city
as a good thing or bombing it as a
reason for war like the crazy emotions
that are involved with that I think for
me I was probably lucky that I was you
know Through Skateboarding introduced a
lot of punk rock elements anti-war
elements so as soon as this all started
the only thing I knew was here's why
it's bad so there was never like I'm not
going to pretend that when I was like
you know 14 15 16 I was this political
genius no I was just some dumb kid
listening to punk rock being like hey
War's bad and then I got older and I
started seeing the stories I started
learning the politics because that that
music got me interested in more
interested in politics and then I was
just outright like yo this is nuts what
they're doing and then Obama comes along
and he's like if you vote for me we're
gonna end the wars and I was like okay I
dig this and this is like my first
presidency and all my friends are like
he's gonna do it man Bush was Hitler and
we're going to get Obama he's changed
he's you know he's going to be the first
black president and I was like all right
you know I'll vote for this guy and then
he right when he gets in office whistle
strike on a Pakistani Village killing
women and children and I was just like I
was pissed I was super pissed I was like
my friends didn't care anymore they're
like oh I don't know what's going on
they stopped paying attention
immediately because it was all a big
propaganda machine I don't think that
there was an actual anti-war movement
for the most part during the bush era I
think it was a Democrat propaganda
movement seeking to exploit the anti-war
effort because they wanted to get a
democrat in office if you look at a lot
of anti-war marches there's a lot of
recruitment for other left-wing causes
that have very little to do with Wars
um yeah and it is it's sort of a
movement building exercise to a certain
extent
yeah man that was that was uh
disheartening to say the least yeah I
thought there was they made me believe
that a savior was gonna save me like
Obama was the savior is what I felt like
and I could actually take a back seat
but that's not you know you're the
you're the driver in this right well
that's almost every president especially
in recent history George W bush ran on a
foreign policy of non-interventional
foreign policy a humble foreign policy
that doesn't get involved in other
countries Affairs that's what he
promised and then the dude just bombed a
whole bunch of countries saying screw it
I'm gonna do what I want give my buddy
Dick Cheney Halliburton whatever he
wants and they lied they lied through
their teeth most wars are based on false
pretenses we could go all the way back
from 1898 with the USS Maine we could go
to the reichtag fire we could go to the
Gulf of Tonkin we could talk about these
events on and on and on and the truth is
there's probably these events happening
right now that the American public
doesn't even know about ah dude all the
videos coming out out of Ukraine and
probably and just one lesson probably
another event that they're preparing for
right now that's going to lead to a
bigger War so I I think that's a big
possibility that I've been speaking
about that we should be looking out for
every single video on Reddit
or Twitter it's always like yeah go
Ukraine and then it's like some
Ukrainian Soldier like flicking a
cigarette an explosion there's another
video where it's like a Russian and
Ukrainian drone got into a sky Fight
ukrainians Win and I'm just like dude
it is like it's propaganda and that's
why I'm annoyed by it they intentionally
want to filter out anything that could
shift morale in this I get it but for me
it is the most annoying thing in the
world when I'm sitting here going like I
know you are lying okay this maybe works
on other people fine leave me out of it
I can look up and see what's actually
going on I can make uh assumptions and
inferences based on the information
received but I'll tell you this 100 of
videos being showing Ukraine winning and
I'm just like spare me okay I'm tired of
it they used video game footage to
promote the ghost of Kiev yup I mean how
how dumb do you think we are the media
ran with it and these people these
people ran with it and it was never
corrected there was never any kind of
real legitimate checks on that specific
story and again I understand propaganda
efforts during war are very uh you know
clearly used against the general public
because they know information is key
when it comes to winning the larger
conflict here but but at least try to
put on a genuine you an effort and not
to treat people like other idiots here
well the video gamification of War has
been 30 years or more in the in the
running and and a lot of people in
comfortable countries where they're
unlikely to have to serve in any of
these wars or fight in any of these wars
do kind of look at it like they're
watching a movie or playing a video game
and you just get to see cool explosions
that's right this uh this Invasion that
Russia just propagated they're they
basically annexed Crimea which was old
Soviet I think and then uh now they're
trying to take the land bridge to Crimea
that's like what the war is about it's
not about killing people it's not about
genocide but potential potentially
lithium uh oxide I think in Crimea or
I've seen some reports about that well
there's a lot of untapped natural gas
resources in those specific regions that
the Russians are having uh under control
right now that are in contention with
the Ukrainian army fighting them I I
think it's the land bridge though
because look they blow up the Crimea
Bridge how is Russia supposed to get
access to Crimea without that bridge
they need another you know those two
highways right yeah they need the land
bridge so I think Armistice is like the
only way out is there some sort of peace
agreement negotiation but what would it
be what would be an effective
negotiation do you see to piece of land
how about we just have them sit at the
table there's people saying you're crazy
you must be you must be a Putin
supporter you must be a peace Nick if
you if you let's just have them sit at
the table and talk to each other at
least let's get to that step we're not
even there zielinski passed the law
saying I'm not negotiating even restated
it I'm not going to be negotiating why
at least talk to each other that's the
first step because let's do that in the
bill yeah he must have some like nasty
video of Joe Biden doing something you
know I think it's funny because they
kept people kept claiming that Putin had
compromat on Trump and I'm like yeah but
what was Trump doing for Russia like he
bombed Syria like you know a half-assed
bombing now you're looking at 100
billion dollars or whatever going to
Ukraine now that sounds like somebody's
got dirt on you yeah because the US why
are we involved in this well Trump sent
lethal weapons to Ukraine as well which
was a big escalation in this entire
conflict there was also a bigger
conflict that could have unfolded with
Iran that luckily didn't unfold but but
but again at the end of the day here the
fact that these people aren't even
willing to negotiate is something that
should be very troubling because if
you're not negotiating if you're not
just coming to the table just to talk
let these people figure it out I don't
have the answers Elon Musk came up with
a proposition it wasn't a perfect
proposition for a peace deal but at
least the conversation was started and I
think the more people call for peace the
more likely we could actually have it
because right now all you're seeing is
deranged lunatic saying war war war with
absolutely no goal in sight and that to
me is reckless that to me is stupid
what's the what's the Strategic
objective here why hasn't anyone told us
this have you guys bought your burnt
hair perfume to help Elon buy Twitter no
not yet I bought that joke so many times
and I think I should get a cut of this
money
about him buying I mean burnt burned
hair I didn't know that he would have
that be the same but I think Elon Musk
your name is musk you have to have a
clone yeah elon's mask please yeah I
need it in my nose it's not the way it
sounds Elon I need it
um yeah I agree with you Luke we need
some sort of diplomacy it could be a
simple video chat with Joe Biden and
Vladimir Putin that's public and they
could be so easy well the United States
of NATO has to be a part of these
negotiations since they're a part of
this conflict and Vladimir Putin just
made a statement a couple days ago
saying that he's willing to actually uh
be open to negotiations during the
upcoming G20 meeting will the West
respond with other negotiations will
they be open to sitting down and talking
to them because this was beyond just
zelinski and and Putin zielinski should
be there obviously zielinski and the
Ukrainian government should be sitting
down with the Russian government and at
least talking to each other in some kind
of capacity in some kind of way
um and and those talks should at least
be between those two countries what do
they want let's let's figure out a way
where they're both happy and it doesn't
have to mean people are getting screwed
over people getting lied about doesn't
mean you're a Putin agent that you just
want conversations to happen I think
there's a desire though to see a
degradation of the Russian military
which they think is most likely to
happen if this conflict continues
but the odd thing is that he called up
300 000 troops so like if you want to
see us conscripts yeah so if you want to
see a weaker military it's not by
forcing them to draft 300 000 people
that's well it also looks like it might
not be the greatest Fighters though to
have from the latest bombings that have
been happening in Ukraine it does look
like the Russians are trying to take out
uh the major air defense systems inside
of Ukraine it looks like they're
preparing for a major bombing campaign
of Ukraine there's also a ton of Russian
soldiers being shipped into Belarus and
there's a lot of rumors that Belarus
will also be participating in launch
another front of this war from the north
of Ukraine so there's a lot of things
happening behind the scenes that are
very much escalating the situation that
are very much unfortunate for all the
innocent people caught in the middle of
this because there's going to be a huge
loss of life I think we should be doing
everything in our power to try to
prevent that and sadly we have the
opposite of that when it comes to the
corporate media when it comes to the
leadership when it comes to the Victoria
Newland and all these other sociopathic
neoconservatives that just want blood
and that's not what I want want I want
the people of Ukraine I want the people
of Russia to to come together and at
least talk to each other thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there